the Persian Gulf is home to vast amounts
of Natural Resources
oil and gas
that mineral wealth puts the region in a
unique position
the abundance of gas in particular could
help those countries who are suffering
from severe shortages following Russia's
decision to cut gas supplies
including Germany
Germans are particularly dependent on
Russian gas to heat homes and fuel
production processes
to compensate for these Supply gaps it's
turning to Gulf States to meet demands
in the hope of brokering new deals with
Qatar Saudi Arabia and the United Arab
Emirates
the Gulf States do have ample reserves
and natural gas it's quite cheap
compared to other sources and they are
very very trained experience in
exporting the gas particularly through
LNG
liquefied natural gas or LNG will be
vital in meeting Germany's energy needs
and Qatar has plenty
on the global market it is the second
largest exporter of LNG but Qatar also
has its own interests
Qatar in particular is a country that is
known to be mostly interested in
reliable and profitable business
relations matter is less interested in
being the guy to fill the Gap but
eventually Qatar is interested to become
a long-term supplier for Germany but
committing to long-term contracts might
not be an option for Germany the
government is transitioning away from
fossil fuels and towards renewable
energy sources
this is where Saudi Arabia could come
into play the kingdom currently wants to
export crude oil and hydrogen to Germany
even though it has the world's eighth
largest proven natural gas reserves it
mainly requires gas for its own domestic
production
Saudi Arabia has now set a target of
doubling gas production by 2030 to meet
new gas demands on the global market
but again national interests could Clash
so in particular Saudi Arabia might
demand Germany to uh to to loosen or
perhaps even to remove uh its uh its
arms export band that Germany introduced
uh particularly with regard to the Yemen
War since 2014 Saudi Arabia has been
heavily involved in the war in Yemen so
relations with Saudi Arabia are
considered politically sensitive
not least because of the ruling princes
suspected involvement in the murder of
journalist Jamaica shogi almost four
years ago
so that leaves the Third Country the
United Arab Emirates as the most likely
partner for a gas deal well I think you
know the Emirates uh can probably offer
what Germany wants right now which is a
short-term contracts such a deal could
be a big boost for Germany with one
caveat
the much needed infrastructure to export
energy supplies does not yet exist this
energy export plans will need about
three to five years to be built so we
know how the market is going to look
like up to 2025 and the problem is that
there is not that much additional LNG
export capacity which is going to come
to the market so the market is going to
be maintained and while many European
countries already have LNG terminals
Germany has yet to build one the
government has five currently in the
pipeline but until then it will be
dependent on European Neighbors
foreign
with that prices are likely going to
stay high and Germany might find itself
making political concessions to others
in order to satisfy its energy needs